hello I'm so glad you can make it
tonight come on in I'll give you the
Grand Tour now we have three new flavors
for everyone to try all in having a good
evening gentlemen
no not a little dry have another dream
in attending tonight means joining our
society it allows you to do whatever you
please I come from oh I don't know
cleric ages there reach for the
strongest person see so drink up
[Music]
so what does our hop which couldn't
catch Nick and getting a fresh melon
flavor and into honey
fastening again it is my honor to
welcome you to our exclusive society sit
back relax and drink to your heart's
content you'll forget all your worries
[Music]
thanks for joining us for this cleansing
affair
my name is cinder and you've probably
heard me over on al dente creepypasta
before no poisons views fair yet you can
find those by clicking here I'm a new
writer producer or whatever on the
channel until cz guys aren't vanishes
Tim back already yeah I'm a drink
thanks hit like if you would enjoy
ice-cold Bleach remember to subscribe to
see these worlds for Horrors every week
bring the desk bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]